hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es
eigentlich ganz besonderes video von mir
und zwar habe ich hier so eine
silikonform die habe ich aus der ukraine
gestellt das hat auch drei oder vier
wochen gedauert ich habe ganz geduldig
gewartet und zwar hat dass sie die nach
klasse hergestellt mit einem 3d drucker
was wirklich auf dieser torte geworden
ist da zeigt euch heute in dem video
jetzt wollte ich euch noch ganz kurz
erzählen wie ich überhaupt drauf
gekommen bin und zwar war ich auch
surfen auf youtube habe den beitrag von
galileo gesät und da hat der liebe
martin dunkelmann genau diese torte
nachgemacht und erhält gesagt das
ergebnis da fühlen wir nicht ganz so gut
und deswegen wollte ich es unbedingt
selber machen mit meinem eigenen rezept
und ja ich hoffe sehr dass die torte
gestellt das galileo video das verlinke
ich euch direkt unten in einer infobox
dann könnt ihr euch das ansehen dann
könnt ihr auch sehen was genau ich meine
und jetzt wünsch euch ganz viel spaß
beim einem video
bevor ich jetzt allerdings mit der
zubereitung starte möchte ich schon mal
ein paar fotos der fertigen torte zeigen
[Musik]
hergestellt habe ich eine joghurt sahne
torte mit einer heide der frucht einlage
und einem lockeren bis geboten
zuallererst backen wir den biskuit boden
und hierfür benötigen wir ein 40 gramm
zucker 40 gramm mehl 1 esslöffel warmes
leitungswasser und einen halben
teelöffel backpulver das algier zusammen
mit dem wasser in eine schüssel geben
und mit einem schneebesen oder einem
mixer cremig gerührt
sobald ihr dann eine schöne cremige
masse erhalten habt kommt noch der
zucker mit hinzu und wird noch mal eine
minute lang weiter gemixt
[Musik]
zu guter letzt wird noch das mehl und
das backpulver hinein gesiebt damit auch
keine klümpchen entstehen und das ganze
wird mit einem teig aber vorsichtig
untergehoben der fertige teig wird dann
in einem mit backpapier ausgelegte
backform gegeben ich habe hier meine
brownie form genommen die hatte die maße
20 x 20 cm
der teig wird nun bei 190 grad ober und
unterhitze für 13 minuten gebacken
weiter geht es mit der frucht einlage
und hier habe ich mich für heidelbeeren
entschieden das sind 200 gramm
außerdem noch 20 gramm zucker da mein
heil wenn nicht so süß waren eine
packung magazine und 100 milliliter
wasser die heidelbeeren gebe ich dann in
meinen kochtopf
wie gesagt habe ich hier 200 gramm
heidelbeeren damit die frucht einlage
aber nicht zu dünn wird fülle ich das
ganze noch mit wasser auf und zwar nehme
ich hier noch 100 meter was habt so habe
ich eine gesamtmenge von 300 gramm
falls euer obst wie bei mir noch nicht
süß genug war gibt dir dann auch den
zucker mit hinzu und anschließend die
alpine das ganze wird dann einmal gut
durch gerührt so dass keine klümpchen
mehr da sind und anschließend püriert
falls ihr aber die stückchen gerne drin
hat in eurer frucht einlage dann könnt
ihr das ganze auch unberührt lassen
[Musik]
nun gebe ich den topf auf mein herz
schallte ihm an und lasse das ganze zwei
minuten lang köcheln
[Musik]
nach exakt zwei minuten ich habe die
zeit gestoppt nehme ich den topf vom
herd und fülle das ganze um auch hier
nämlich wieder die gleiche backform wie
vorhin beim biscuit boden und wichtig
ist dass er sie vorher auslegt
frischhaltefolie hat bei mir nicht so
gut funktioniert aber ich empfehle euch
da gefrierbeutel zu nehmen nun schwenke
ich noch ein bisschen hin und her damit
auch die frucht einlage in der form
überall gleichmäßig verteilt wird und
gebe das ganze für ca drei stunden ins
gefrierfach für die leckere joghurt
sahne creme benötigen wir 400 milliliter
kalte schlagsahne zwei packungen
magazine zwei esslöffel vanille extrakt
80 gramm puderzucker 600 gramm joghurt
und 150 milliliter wasser um die creme
schönen standfest zu bekommen gebe ich
zu allererst das wasser mit der agad ine
in einen kochtopf und rühre das ganze
klümpchen frei erst dann schalte ich den
herd ein und lasse das aufkochen und
jetzt müsst ihr einfach nur rührend
wieder mal zwei minuten lang köcheln
lassen denn erst wenn ihr das ganze zwei
minuten lang köcheln lässt kann das
ganze auch studieren
die ak tine mischung nehme ich vom herd
und lasse sie ein paar minuten stehen
und so lange geht es weiter mit der
sahne die sahne wird jetzt steif
geschlagen und wichtig ist dass sie aus
dem kühlschrank kommt sie muss also
komplett kalt sein
dann gebe ich das auch zur seite und es
geht weiter mit der agah tine und dem
joghurt der joghurt gebe ich in eine
separate schüssel und süße das ganze mit
puderzucker und vanille extrakt
ich habe hier übrigens 3,5 prozentigen
joghurt genommen ihr könntet aber auch
genauso zehnprozentigen nehmen damit die
kreml ihren kann und keine klümpchen
entstehen muss jetzt einen
temperaturausgleich vorgenommen werden
und hierfür gebe ich zuallererst ein bis
zwei esslöffel des joghurts india
gardine mischung wichtig ist dass ihr
die ak tine dabei ständig umringt mit
eurem schneebesen denn ansonsten
entstehen dort schon die klümpchen und
das könnt ihr nicht wieder rückgängig
machen
zur sicherheit gebe ich hier noch
weitere esslöffel des joghurts in die
aktive mischung und rühre dass kräftig
um
nun geben wir die magazine mit zum
joghurt und auch hier müssen wir ständig
umrühren
an dieser stelle ist das ganze noch
ziemlich flüssig es wird aber gelieren
sobald ihr eine temperatur von 35 grad
erreicht habt anschließend haben wir mit
einem teig schaber die seine unter die
joghurt masse wie joghurt sahne creme
ist nun fertig und wir verwenden sie
auch schon sofort weiter und jetzt kommt
endlich der spannende teil ich habe hier
die silikon form die ich verwenden
möchte und zur stabilisierung gab es
noch so einen kasten mit dabei dann kann
auch nichts passieren
zuallererst schneide ich jetzt indiskret
boden zurecht und zwar so dass er genau
in die form reinpasst die frucht einlage
schneide ich jeweils 2 cm kleiner um die
silikonform jetzt befüllen zu können
müssen wir die joghurt sahne creme
frisch weiter verarbeiten sie darf also
noch nicht verlieren und ich gebe circa
die hälfte der creme in die form
[Musik]
damit sich die creme in alle reden
gleichmäßig verteilt und wir auch beim
abziehen der silikonform ein schönes
ergebnis haben knüpfe ich ein paarmal
damit auf die arbeitsfläche darauf geben
wir dann die heidelbeeren frucht einlage
und verteilen darüber den rest der
joghurt sahne creme jetzt noch mal ein
bisschen hin und her zwischen damit sich
die creme auch gut verteilt und wir
geben dem bild oben drauf der boden kann
jetzt noch ganz leicht angedrückt werden
damit er sich der form auch anpasst und
wer einen geraden abschluss haben und
dann wickel ich das ganze in
frischhaltefolie ein und die torte muss
komplett durchfrieren das ziel
mindestens sechs stunden im gefrierfach
oder wie in meinem fall über nacht für
die hübsche samtige optik auf der torte
hat jetzt dieses velvet spray gesorgt
und zwar ist das ein samt spray aus der
dose mit hochwertiger kakaobutter
die müsst ihr kräftig schütteln und
anschließend auf die gefrorene torte
sprühen
des weiteren habe ich mich für die
vertiefungen der torte für eine schwarze
moor place entschieden und die gibt es
auch schon gebrauchsfertig zu kaufen
[Musik]
meine torte kommt jetzt frisch aus dem
gefrierfach und ich befreie sie zunächst
von ihrer form
[Musik]
wichtig ist dass ihr diese die grundform
behutsam und langsam ab macht damit euch
auch nichts kaputt geht oder abbricht
[Musik]
so sieht die torte nun aus und wir
möchten die jetzt natürlich noch
verschönern mit unserem samt spray und
mit dem mirror place und hier müssen wir
zügig arbeiten denn die gefrorene torte
muss jetzt mit dem song pray eingedeckt
werden wichtig ist dass sie wirklich
tief gefroren ist ansonsten funktioniert
der effekt leider nicht das spray sprich
dann von ca 20 zentimeter entfernung auf
die torte und hier seht ihr schon wie
sich die farbe von eierschalen gelb auf
weiß verändert hat das velvet spray gibt
es übrigens in mehreren farben hier
unten rechts im bild habe ich die rote
variante getestet die fand ich auch sehr
schön
als nächsten schritt habe ich mir ein
teil der minigames in meine schüssel
abgefüllt und das ganze in der
mikrowelle erhitzt damit sich die
bestandteile bot auflösen und dann
bringe ich die temperatur unter auf 25
grad
an dieser stelle müsst ihr
fingerspitzengefühl beweisen und ich
muss zugeben ich war so nervös dass ich
total gezittert habe aber es hat
gottseidank funktioniert und mir ist
kein patzer passiert
[Musik]
die architektur torte ist somit fertig
und wichtig ist nur dass sie vor dem
anschnitt vier bis sechs stunden lang im
kühlschrank gelagert wird
[Musik]
selbstverständlich zeige ich euch die
torte auch noch im anschnitt und sowohl
innen als auch außen hat die torte für
mich 100 punkte außerdem hat sie
geschmacklich auch total meinen nerv
getroffen weil es nicht so schwer im
magen lag und durch diese joghurt creme
total leicht war
ich hoffe dass euch das video gefallen
hat und hier könnt ihr mich übrigens
abonniert damit ihr auch keines meiner
videos mehr verpasst und hier kommt ihr
zu dem letzten beiden videos bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss